da ist er noch meine adresse
hallo
hallo ich habe schon auf sie gewartet
perfektes ein kostüm
das ist furchtbar aus ich habe mein
konto ich habe vergessen wie dieses teil
heißt ich habe wieder meinen meine decke
to go ich habe meine decke to go wieder
gefunden und hab mir gedacht warum ich
sie drei jahre nicht getragen laut
meinem haus sollte ich eigentlich etwas
blaues tragen aber heute ist es halt
grün leute es ist soweit wenn es könne
aus videos sind keine bänder aus videos
wenn nicht ein harry potter
adventskalender dabei ist wir hatten
schon ein mit dem lego das habe ich
wieder vergessen ich dachte das wäre
dann wenn ihr euch jetzt fragt war dass
er warum schon wieder ein rc
adventskalender versuchst du stress auf
seinem kanal zu erzeugen ja tue ich ich
stehe auf dünnem eis und liebe es sehr
am herzen sein was soll ich sagen ich
hab den adventskalender zusammen mit dem
anderem advanced kalender bestellt und
ja
bevor wir sehen uns klären aber
anschauen gucken wir einmal hinter die
kulissen der adventskalender dem wir uns
heute anschauen habe ich auf etsy
gefunden und zwar ist es kein
offizieller adventskalender es ist ein
harry potter inspiriert adventskalender
ich habe ihn für 65 euro geschossen und
zwar am 19 september der shop heißt
reading book shop und bei verkauf der
sohn ja so
zeugs viele kerzen viele kerzen tasten
den letzten habe ich 83 bezahlt mit
versand und für den 65
unser harry potter etc da
[Musik]
die tür machen mich aggressiv wir haben
einen brief gekriegt wir haben einen
brief krieg wir haben einen prüfbericht
ich frag mich nur von vanessa oder soll
ich lieber sagen hallo youtube kollegin
nachdem ich dein letztes video etc
advents kalender geschaut habe musste
ich sofort in meine besteller liste
schauen und nach deinem namen suchen
fand ich wollte dir privat da ich weiß
dass du port au prince kölner magst
tatsächlich einfach so ein zukommen
lassen und hatte dafür schon studie 71
kontaktiert um eine adresse zu haben zu
der das paket schicken könnt jetzt bin
ich aber umso mehr gespannt wie du
diesen kalender auch bewertet und habe
echt respekt dürfe
ich hab das gefühl habe hat mich gerade
so was von bekommen eigentlich ist der
kalender immer mehr für meine eigene
youtube community gedacht und eben für
die sich auch auf meine seite führen
umso schöner dass du auch dorthin
gefunden hat wie du willst macht immer
was die spaß macht und das auf dich auch
riina
leader toll wie
so ein restaurantkritiker der jetzt
aufgefallen ist
eigentlich bin ich mal anonym unterwegs
aber jetzt haben mich die restaurant
leute gegrüßt
bisschen diesen tisch baukonzern
probieren weist seidenpapier melina
megageil wieder verwendbar kann ich
super gut gebrauchen besteller 46 für
die adventskalender
liebe vanessa vielen lieben dank für
deine bestellung schön dass für den
ersten 50 bestellung gehört wodurch du
ein kleines extra limitiertes
kombi geredet denn wenn et orbi karte
und als sie diesen brief geschrieben hat
wusste sie noch nicht dass ich das bin
und den großen garbsen spoiler umschlag
war auf melina wellpappe mega gut ohligs
wert auf sicherheit das merkt man noch
ein schutz papier das war ich natürlich
alles auf
richtig fette special ich weiß nicht ob
ihr das erkennen könnt aber es ist ein
schönes paket so export würde ich noch
nie im export
[Musik]
li na was soll ich jetzt sage halt
einfach mal antue hier nummer eins
leihen
der brave leyen riecht nach ich würde
sagen himbeer kurzem dort thema dürfen
nicht vergessen es ist ein harter
angelehnte hat man es können daran kein
offizieller wir haben hier nicht hohl
das mal aus glauben
die 24 ist großzügig nochmals zwei bist
und ich sehe schon die kommentare jetzt
hat überlässt es ja nicht so ernst
bewertet wie sonst weil sie angst hat
vor lasst mich doch einfach mal ein
lukas pakets war ein wunderschöner
wetterau
sexy blonde nummer zwei
[Musik]
findet bei ups ksk
wasserfarben sehr gute idee wenn man
illustration nach der noch als
postkarten dann so zu füllen
und ja ein
porträt also besser wäre es natürlich
wenn sich das porträt bewegen würde wie
in harry potter aber naja gut machen wir
weiter ich muss ein bisschen kritik
einbauen dass die nummer 3 gibt mir
wirklich harry potter weiß das ist
irgendwie so ein paket wie in der
winkelgasse nummer 3 befindet sich masse
und in dieser watte
zaubertränke bitte nicht öffnen nicht
zum verzehr geeignet
melina ich sag dir warte war eine gute
idee zum verpacken hh ist ein bisschen
kritisch inhalt das setzt sich hier ab
da muss man erst mal das wieder sauber
um vom know how um eine kritik zu geben
was haben wir hier wir haben zwei
zaubertränke die wirklich
herzallerliebst flow pulver ich werde
nicht mehr sieht das christian thies
krauth ua
hvb mein gott
bleiben wir kritisieren hier hart nummer
vier schwer
hanni die jungs
auch bei mir die kerze nicht süß aber
das kann auch sein hier haben wir wieder
eine kerze
cool hanni die jungs nach der honigtopf
oder wie ich musste das ist natürlich
google weil ich von hand auf den
honigtopf gekommen bin ist natürlich der
honigtau klasse ist natürlich blöd wenn
man englisch
gold wie der schwanz
es ist ein kleiner bilder wahr ist das
niedlich wie klein das ist ein ganz
kleiner bilder
nikolaus melina nikolaus ein kleines
weckler nikolaus klingt aber
vielversprechend
jawoll für dieses zeug bin ich hier aus
für diesen scheiß bin ich hier und her
schnatz als schlüsselanhänger reden wer
die ist ja voll gemacht man weiß sofort
was es ist aber ich glaube es wurde
einfach nur mit einer goldenen kugel und
zwei fühlen quasi gebastelt aber es
sieht so simpel und einfach gut aus
schönes nikolaus geschenk hätte aber
größer sein können melina
türchen nummer 7 ich hätte mich jetzt
dolores verkleiden sollen
per boten arbeit thanks for the german
melina jetzt kann ich auch endlich
verstehe den ganzen englischen worten
weiß man ja gar nicht was gemeint ist
das riecht nach
wald goldig und grünen glitzer nummer
acht ist wieder ein säckchen
einmal genäht ich habe einen kühlschrank
an den nicht magnet darin machen können
und es sind die heiligtümer des todes ja
das macht ganz cool man heute ist sehr
groß es freut mich kommt drauf an
besitzt drin bailey planer
da kann man ein
daily planer für den tischen dann kann
man nochmal angeben was für ein tag
und monat ist und die priorität und
termine todo und idee einfach so ein
kleines notizbuch klein für den tisch
den ganzen haus 4 und julina wusste dass
sie nummer 9 gut sein muss in nummer 10
befindet sich neue bachelor also
havelpark kriegt an i
woaß wien duftrosen ich war's nicht
definieren melina alle fragen die zu
diesem adventskalender beantworte sie
einfach unten in den kommentaren wenn du
das siehst ich will sagen kann miller
aber natürlich immer wieder eine zeit
also wenn jetzt ich nicht gezeichnet
wurde dann
weil die jungs mir gesagt ich
sage wenn harry potter im anime wäre
oder herzallerliebst dass sie wirklich
sehr sehr süß vor allem romans puzzle
für richtig
wir sind bei der hälfte angekommen aber
austin ex horst tippel source of magic
elvis damit ein zitat von dumbledore als
lesezeichen mit dem hogwarts igel
eingewachsen mit dem brief siegel damit
man noch mal den potter lesen kann ich
als online audio aber ich bin jetzt das
jetzt dass man diese nummer 13 oh mein
gott wieder eine kerze die
harry potter kerzen die hat man gar
nicht versucht ein thema zu suchen das
straight harry potter in your face und
harry potters doch kann ich nicht ich
will immer kirche himbeere irgendwie
sowas sagen aber kann ich nicht
entziffern und es wieder sein gold stets
am start nur wahnsinn eine kerze raum
der wünsche
ich finde das ganz toll diese
thematischen kerzen in dieser kerze gibt
es eine überraschung rennen die kerze
abend nehme vorsichtig das päckchen
heraus dass ich war ja irgendwas
verpackt und er dürfte es vandalismus
seien also dass wenn das jetzt nicht was
mit meinem riechorgan ja die ist einfach
schlicht weiß und irgend was verbirgt
sich in dieser kerze
nummer 14 15 1
klar
wird ein pin auf dem stets waiting ich
auch still waiting
geil den finde ich gut noch 16
level das bin ich racing klar nicht mal
als ob er gebrochen ich weiß auch nicht
blau wäre würde ich sagen aber es ist
irgendwie zu ordnen bei blau sich ganz
ganz herzlich gestaltete sticker das ist
ja auf dem shop ja auch so mit das
stärkste also kerzen selbst gemacht
deswegen beschwert euch jetzt mal nicht
wegen ganzen kerzen deinen kommentaren
ruhig mal den job an
dann gibt es 17 drin wasser hinzufügen
hier haben wir wirklich konsumgüter
wachstums trank
ein stück schokolade im fall eines die
mentoren angriffs und vorzüglich
deswegen haben selbst gemacht der
reporter wenn es keine auch einen
richtigen charme weil man so was machen
können oder weil leute die dafür
zuständig sind bei news of the world
oder wie das anders sie kommen nicht aus
so eine gute idee und hier immer was zum
wasser hinzufügen auf heizungs trank
rips schärfung strong und wachstums
trank und hier sind noch mal die
intershop key-user 8 wir haben dann
bilderrahmen
das sieht ja cool aus hier ist kein
künstler verzeichnet das heißt ich
glaube nicht dass sie das selbst gemalt
haben habe wie geil sieht das bitte aus
kuwait nummer 19 eine kerze 934 na klar
und duftrichtung ich habe absolut keine
ahnung am ende schreibt mir den
addierten alle keinen duft das wäre
super peinlich weil ich manchmal meine
wirklich was zu riechen vom look gefällt
mir die gerade glaube ich am besten die
hat somit dem schwarzen deckel und der
schwarzen zahlen und diesen gründen
sticker die hat richtig also schick
gekommen zu unserem letzten säckchen
doch daher denn cooleres motiv
reingekommen ich sag's ehrlich wie sie
es seit der zeitung gera oder
irgendwo irgendwas anderes aber ein
bisschen kitschig 21 und die haben das
zweite paket und den letzten bahn
tauschens drin ich hoffe dass jetzt hier
auch noch welche gesund sind also die
badeseen heftig melina
nächstes mal stroh die flüssigkeit sieht
cool aus hätte das aber glaube ich
ehrlich gesagt noch mitnehmen haken
gemacht dass man das als kette tragen
kann einhorn blut und das sieht so aus
die das zeug was man im ersten teil da
gesehen hat im verbotenen wald
sieht geil aus mega power trank und da
hört wieder mein harry potter wissen
jetzt gerade auf mega power trank ist
das ein job oder einfach das erhöht
damit rein des einen grund sieht
fabelhaft ausweiten 20 sag mal du hier
etwa
eine kerze drin weiß nie wie snake ja
schlittern braucht mehr noch hier in
green apple ich würde ein green apple
sondern grüne kerze ich habe viele
kerzen nummer 23 vorletztes kirchen
dramatisches nehme aber auch hier wieder
warum bewegt sich das bild man kann hier
hinten ist deshalb mehr als anime
charaktere gezeichnet geil neuer es ist
eine voll cool idee die mal in so einem
anderen stil zu sehen dass ich auch so
einen bilderrahmen reinpacken das sieht
auch gut aus so und nun haben wir den 24
wir haben den advent hinter uns gebracht
wir haben passions bekommen haben kleine
schokolade bekommen schlüssel an
bilderrahmen der liblarer hier ein
kleines bilden lesezeichen postkarte und
alles was das herz begehrt das
inoffizielle und jetzt ist die 24 darum
gehen runter zu unserem adventskalender
oder er steht in unserem zimmer
danke melina
verpackungsmaterial
als wenn du das jetzt noch selber
bezeichnet hast das wäre ich geil aber
da weiß ich das nicht aber wenn ich das
jetzt auch gar nicht zu sehr sagen
melina
tolle tasse bis jetzt diese tasse sehr
sehr geil finde die hat das harry potter
thema war es irgendwie so unauffällig
cute einfach mit diesen zeichnungen
darauf von den einzelnen pushen dass die
nicht sogleich war dann deine fresse ich
trinke seine potter tasse sondern so was
ist ja verschiedene potion ich würde
liga feiern wenn du dich selbst
gezeichnet hast eine sehr sehr schöne
tasse ja jetzt ist die frage welches
fazit gibt es von mir
nun ja
was kostet der scheiß seinem shop also
dafür 560 euro saßen toll gestalteter
liebevoll verpackte adventskalender mit
tollen ideen die puschen lassen mein
herz höher schlagen es lustig ist ja das
original harry potter märz so unfassbar
teuer dass man ja hier sogar sagen kann
richtig gespannt solche sachen kosten
original vielmehr also ich finde diesen
schlüsselanhänger mit den flügeln und
die goldene kugel richtig cool auch so
ein selbstgemachtes lesezeichen ist
total süß und macht so sehen und will
ihn ja gesagt habt der adventskalender
ist für ihre zuschauer so also die auch
so also wenn man sie kennt und verfolgt
dann macht's wie sind und manche leute
verirren sich dann halt auch auf den
show so wie ich in was schöner welt
würde ich jetzt etwas schlechtes über
diesen adventskalender sagen auf gar
keinen fall durch mir das an ich also
mir fällt auch nicht so wirklich was
schlecht ist deswegen sage ich an dieser
stelle nicht ich freue mich dass ihr
also fleißig zugeschaut hat und morgen
das leider
und dann ist da und ich freue mich
ehrlich gesagt auch ein ganz bisschen
weil die begrenzt kalender auch für
dieses jahr erst mal so ist oben hin uns
dann nochmal
den umschlag mit insidern bevor ich gehe
hat ist der umschlag mittlerer alle
voller hass und ihr könnt jetzt wenn ihr
das richtig cool fand followers count
instagram hier seht ihr das nochmal
bitte schön hier ist noch rehna die eine
art verdient
fabrik.de hallo folgt auch trainer
diener und hier ist wirklich eine liste
mit den dingen ok alles klar und ihr
channel auf youtube heißt die ruhigen
bei channel das sind ihre social und
damit peace out ist
dann ist sowie endlich frei